hi I'm Erik Bosse since Star Trek the
car dropped a trailer at comic-con that
a lot of people are talking about but
Patrick Stewart returning as jean-luc
Picard for the first time since Star
Trek nemesis is Charles Xavier days are
done and he's back to the good stuff
this is a series that I'm super curious
about with not just references to the
next generation but like crossovers from
Voyager and we're now wading into the
frontiers where my Trekkie expertise is
limited so I have asked my good friend
in huge Star Trek nerd marina Mastro's
to break it down for us hi marina hi
Erik don't worry I can explain why every
Star Trek fan is losing their [ __ ] right
now so you may have seen how marina was
awesome helping us break down the recent
itch chapter two trailers shot-by-shot
and you're gonna do the same with this
Picard trailer yeah mm-hmm I'm gonna
explain why all the new details and
visual clues in this trailer you might
have actually overlooked
spoiler alert in case I actually explain
too much Thank You marina whoo okay
let's get started with the first clip
from this trailer have you ever been a
stranger to yourself many many times
[Music]
the trailer opens on shaft LP called his
family vineyards in lebar France
Picard's older brother robert and nephew
Rene tragically died in a fire and now
automated machines harvest the grapes
and bottle the wine wine that Picard
shared with the crew during Riker and
Troy's wedding in nemesis and I was
screaming at the reveal of Picard's old
combadge notice that it has these square
shaped wings meaning it's the
communicator that Picard were in the
movies moving on two decades ago data
sacrificed his life few years I really
tried but it never truly felt like home
okay here Picard reminds us of how
Commander data sacrificed himself
referring to the ending of Nemesis when
data destroyed Shinzon's villarin weapon
and himself to save the enterprise and
everyone on it
beaming Picard to safety I'm not crying
you're crying there's an overhead shot
of the Android in segments which is
actually how I sleep and brent Spiner
was asked about this shot he said that
he thinks this is Android before the
data doppelganger in nemesis there's
also an overhead shot of Picard walking
in his vineyards with his new dog named
number one which is very cute a nod to
his nickname for commander Riker and
next generation in the comic-con panel
it was revealed that Jonathan Frakes
will appear as record with Marina Sirtis
is counselor Troi in some of the
episodes which is my dream come true
maybe we'll get a moment where Riker
realizes he shares the name with the dog
like that joke an Indiana Jones on to
the next clip
do you know who I am everything inside
of me says that I'm safe with you you
know I have encountered a woman she came
to me for help in this section picard
appears on holographic TV suggesting
he's a pretty famous dude which he
absolutely should be and that's how he
was found by papa this mystery woman
named dodge so who is dodge well notice
the scar on her forehead that means she
could be former Borg but my thought is
that she could be Picard's daughter with
the Borg Queen from first contact with
the Borg Queen bearing a child from the
assimilated Picard or Locutus before he
killed her but there are a lot of
theories floating around she also could
be law data's daughter or or okay just
stay with me here she could actually be
a John Connor type of character who will
eventually go back in invent the Borg
which would make Picard the Terminator
and I am here for it we also see Picard
at Starfleet headquarters in San
Francisco later in the trailer we see
that he arrives here via transporter
pads similar to the ones in the more
recent Star Trek beyond though just as a
reminder that's the rebooted Kelvin
timeline not the prime timeline which
Picard takes place in now notice the new
Starfleet uniforms they keep the colors
of the officers track from
next-generation thank God
yellow for engineering and security blue
for science and medicine and red for
command these colors drape across the
shoulders and the rest of the uniform is
black and very classy it now appears
that holographic technology has become
standard in this new era that's right TV
shows have VFX budgets now moving on
slicing shoes
she's in serious danger
sometimes I worry that you have
forgotten who you are here picard
watches as dodge fights helmeted
security forces that could be from
Starfleet itself since the falling
henchman is beamed in midair presumably
to safety
perhaps Starfleet is trying to apprehend
dodge explaining why Picard has to go
outside his former service for his new
mission moving on to a shot of enemy
ships presumably new Romulan warbirds
approaching an unknown planet then a
very interesting shot of some kind of
medical procedure on a Borg body notice
the Romulans are wearing masks this
shows how they're taking all precautions
to prevent an outbreak and assimilation
into the Borg collective and before I
move on there's a shot of this banner
for Captain Picard a which they used to
celebrate on the USS Enterprise which
always made Picard uneasy this could be
a flashback to happier times or it could
be a hint at his new crew which could be
the now grown children from his old ship
which would be really funny because he
hated those kids at the time next clip
[Music]
do not you can't do it alone
need help
[Music]
you need protection
you need a crew
people kept and they remember here we
see Romulans are keeping board prisoners
and there's a sign that reads this
facility has gone five thousand eight
hundred and forty three days without an
assimilation it's kind of nuts that this
is the sign they would have as opposed
to just like writing the number on a
wall and everyone knowing what it means
but then again you can't blame them for
taking assimilation so seriously because
resistance is futile I'll also point out
that five thousand eight hundred and
forty three days is just over sixteen
years which isn't that far from the
release of Star Trek nemesis and then we
meet the new cast yes I am here for it
there's Chris Rios Santiago Cabrera a
skilled thief and pilot of Picard's new
ship Alison Pill plays doctor Agnes
jarate a researcher there's also
Michelle heard as Rafi massacre a former
Starfleet intelligence officer with ties
to Picard who struggles with substance
abuse
Evan evoke aura plays Elinor a young
long-haired Romulan fiercely loyal to
Picard as everyone should be and an
expert in melee combat essentially
Picard is going to be a captain again
and I'm [ __ ] my pants move on she
has no idea what she truly is
[Music]
in this section we meet another new cast
member Harry tried away playing Narvik
saying she has no idea what she truly is
on the far right of the frame there's a
red light beaming through a window with
what looks like a Romulan symbol
suggestion that it could be a Romulan
ship maybe they stole it maybe they
didn't we don't know another character
growls she's the end of it all
she's the destroyer again we could be
looking at a Borg human hybrid or that
inventor or founder theory of the Borg
dodj sits on a bed beside a stuffed
animal that kind of reminds me of a
Tribble it looks like one of the
upcoming Star Trek shorts we'll bring
back tribbles and then we get an awesome
shot of the Borg cube okay I was
screaming I was screaming but notice how
it's damaged plates are missing from its
hull it appears to be hollowed out and
the ship lights are blue and not green
and Romulan ships are surrounding it
suggesting maybe the Romulans captured
it stripped its technology and are
experimenting with it to create
cybernetically enhanced hybrids we know
that Jonathan del arco will return us
Huw the Borg that Picard and the
Enterprise crew freed from the
collective and that history will pick up
where it left off in next generation
episode descent part two leading a group
of freed Borg drones on to the next
cliff the hell are you doing out here
Picard saving the galaxy
and gay hot damn we got 709 baby Jeri
Ryan is back with a crossover from Star
Trek Voyager which is just everything I
want in life her character was a former
assimilated Borg with her original name
being Annika Hansen so presumably she'll
have a pretty major role to play in this
board centric story and in a rapid-fire
montage there's a quick shot of a Borg
corpse I'm wondering if this could
actually be Hugh and Jellico's continued
role in this new series we'll be in this
GUI form and that brings us to Picard
saying engage and so many parts of me
just made it so on to the final clip of
the trailer I don't want the game to end
I can see that captain
yes [ __ ] get it is back though again
it's not totally clear if this is beef
or or data here or a fee for has become
data by importing his memory engrams
they're playing poker in what looks like
a kind of a void so they actually could
be on a holodeck and of course the card
is drinking tea Earl Grey
piping hot tea speak the words that are
on all of our minds none of us want this
game to end and thankfully with the
return of brent Spiner as data as well
as the appearances of Riker
Troy Hugh and 7:09 the game never has to
end
jean-luc Picard is gonna live forever
because Patrick Stewart is gonna live
forever
yes now if you'll excuse me I'm gonna
hyperventilate until 2020 what are you
most looking forward to with this new
Picard series comment down below with
your thoughts and subscribe to new rock
stars with more breakdowns of all the
stuff you love I'm marina Mastro's
thanks for watching
[Music]